you've been dropping a lot
I wouldn't say that man I feel like I
kind of like no I mean I just feel like
you've been applying like non-stop
pressure man like
this uh it's moderate
it's pretty hey you know it's it's nice
it's moderate we're gonna get heavy
though we're getting Heavy after this
well that's what I keep hearing right I
keep hearing that you have like this
body of work that you're working on
that's like the real album yeah like
some crazy singles you got crazy
features
but you've been just throwing out kind
of like these projects yeah independent
you do what you want now you know right
right so the end of the year I'm working
on a like that project
that's like that thing that's gonna be
timeless not for the time you know what
I mean so I've been I've been working on
that for a minute
um I've heard some names that are
supposed to be on that project
yes a few it's a few good yeah it's a
Few Good Men on there I heard you got
some baby you got some big names on
there some big features yeah it's a feel
good man it's a care to share it's
feeling good
uh when it's time
okay because I know when it's time we'll
drop the bomb for sure how did the uh
gangster girls thing happen
um like cheesy so like my guy Lake yeah
Lake shazy 2021
when I uh
just like got made my mind up and got
focused and started doing it it like
just start connecting immediately on the
Underground and um like cheesy have been
hollering at me and I had it was a few
like L.A Summers 2 was supposed to be a
gangster grills but I just didn't feel
like
I wanted it to be a like I wanted to be
a gangster grills when I make a gangster
Grill so I wanted to feel like a mixtape
but like an album at the same time so
that's what this hot shot is but the
conversation been going on for a year
and the crazy thing is
um you know Lake reached out to me you
know usually it's people like man I need
a gangster girls dying for it and it's
always been a goal of mine because when
I was growing up Gangster grills was
that [__] of course that's all you heard
so like this is definitely something off
the bucket list and um you know uh Lake
was hitting me but I didn't really think
nothing of it I'm like I'm just thinking
he's saluting hey we should do a project
right and you know how to enter well
like ain't an industry [__] not at all
work in the industry yeah for sure but
you know how a lot of people just be
like hey let's work let's do something
that never happens so I didn't really um
like really just take it too serious and
then I was in um I'm in [__] Vegas
taking my daughter I took my daughter
shopping I'm in the Aria and um
I'm running down to what's that Javier's
yeah Javier is a Mexican spotted so I'm
upstairs in the room tired just tore it
down for my daughter and um I'm like I'm
hungry I ain't ate [__] all day I rushed
down to Javier's
to see if the kitchen is still open
um somebody yanked my arm I'm like who
the [__] is this it's a lb cousin I go
to the back lbnm runs lb yeah it runs
jokes up man they got the whole back of
the restaurant sold up right so I sit
and I ain't even have to order [__] it's
food everywhere I'm eating
and um I met this guy named Rob Liddy he
owned a company called Liddy he like
what you doing pay me to do a private
party like and it was like a
like damn near more than what I get paid
for a lot of shows I only did two verses
but
Jeezy was also performing there and
um gz camera guy I know I'm from going
to uh
to uh drama in them studio and [__]
right and he's like man what's up when
that gangster girl is coming out
that's what he tell me and I'm like
gangster girls what you mean and he like
yeah drama and Lake been talking about
it I said oh this [__] is serious right
so that's when I'm like yeah let's get
this [__] done and um did you do you
don't have to pay drama for that uh
it's love it's love
or love we definitely gave up a few
dollars but nothing nowhere to what it
was just like the money I gave him was
just a token of my appreciation thank
you yeah yeah but it was like what he
get like it was like not even a [__]
10 for that [__] right so
um did Lake try to sign you to
generation now
um nah we never had a conversation like
that but you know I got to full support
and all that so but it is you know
something a possibility scheme for a
while you know yeah yeah it's definitely
a possibility but
um I'm just man I'm enjoying um Empire
and Perico's Enterprise like yep I'm
[__] like in the best position I ever
been like Fame wise
this uh whatever but like you know
financials and the [__] that I could do
and the type of different business calls
I'm getting especially with this thing
where everybody's selling catalog and
[__] yeah I've been getting these like
no [__] no exaggeration I've been
getting like multi-million dollar offers
for your catalog yeah
and it's like
I feel like I ain't even hit that
[__] Peak or got to a place where we
invested because I haven't spent no
money on marketing or anything at all
yet